es ist faszinierend und lässt selbst
experten rätseln der tal vulkan
schleudert asche und gestein 15
kilometer hoch in die atmosphäre und
erzeugt seine eigenen blitze der
ausbruch ein sensationelles
naturschauspiel vor allem wegen der lage
des vulkans mitten in einem see
doch so faszinierend der anblick so groß
die gefahr
tausende bewohner rund um den see sind
schon geflohen überall verwandelt sich
die asche in klebrigen schlamm oder sie
brennt in den augen wir haben alles
zurücklassen alle sind abgehauen
wir sind hier her gerannt überall viel
dicker asche und gestein vom himmel
der internationale flughafen von manila
auch er vom ascheregen betroffen mehr
als 240 flüge wurden bereits gestrichen
der tat zählt mit seinen 300 meter hohen
krater wänden zwar zu den kleinsten aber
auch zu den aktivsten vulkanen der welt
der letzte ausbruch 1977 jetzt 40 jahre
später brodelt er wieder so gefährlich
dass vulkanologen die alarmstufe hoch
gesetzt haben der eigentliche
gigantische ausbruch könnte kurz bevor
stehen wird das brodeln also noch
schlimmer schätzen behörden müssen
hunderttausende fliehen
eine massenevakuierung bei der dann
niemand mehr zeit für solche aufnahmen
haben wird